i realized
we are
terrified as a human race
we're so scared of cancer
we need to embrace someone's fears
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel at stanford
leap and birthright excel
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders this one is special and you're
about to hear why
meet vanessa paramal managing director
of jt communication solutions
vanessa is a leading south african
strategist former journalist media and
communications specialist and social
entrepreneur who is currently using her
rare cancer to highlight the importance
of resilience community and african
excellence during a time of
unprecedented challenges for the world
vanessa paramahl thank you so much for
joining me on 20 minute leaders i'm
really excited to have you here this is
going to be
an amazing episode um you know when i
think about leadership you know you
embody leadership uh
whether it's through you know media and
communication strategist and and running
an amazing agency but but also some some
interesting you know life adversities
that have you know led you to become
even a stronger leader in your domain
and so what i'd love to do in these 20
minutes is to get to know you better and
get to know your mindset better and and
how you've handled that adversity so so
vanessa tell me tell me a little bit
about yourself and and let's start from
a little bit about you know what are you
doing and what happened this last year
my name is
[Music]
you really have to have
connections
or you have to have casual or you have
to have investments
otherwise
we are coming to you from now
the geographical location becomes a
barrier for an opportunity
so that's number one
number two while you please with your
notes
i wanna show you something
on my neck
[Music]
and even though i went
by
[Music]
is to normalize my life
when i got into hospital
you know people not scared to go into
australia because they died
i found it ideal
but none of them
[Music]
my money
from
[Music]
it
vanessa take me back to
to when you discover that that you're
not gonna be able to use your your
previous voice anymore you know as a
leader as a you know on the radio and
as a media and
media and communications strategist you
understand the power of voice
what what what how what goes to your
mind at that point how how do you even
deal with that
you know we are traveling
over the last 20 years we travel like
six weeks every year just to clear my
brain i go with my kids
but in 2019 i hadn't been feeling well
and i did
testing and testing
[Music]
i already had my gown
and
[Music]
i can never get my weight
however
[Music]
goldman remember
so i was the
best of them
people were praying for me
from cuba to the united states from
germany to australia
people were praying for me from
[Music]
so
i did not know
[Music]
social media
wow
[Music]
i'm now learning that i'm a good leader
because my entrepreneurs
have died
and not even my goal when they come in
right they have no money like me i'm
badly
however
it's
much more easier to struggle
and you have a challenge when you get
responsible
so i think i made a very good medical
team
because
[Music]
right now as you
go through life right now
and you're
communicating obviously and you're
speaking and you're
you're still strategist by nature and i
can see that this is a pattern of who
you are
you know in your core
where where do you see yourself now what
what how is this
new reality impacting you as a leader
you as a strategist you know whether
it's with your professional agency
whether it's in your personal life or
what you want to do later on how is this
changing things
to give me a platform
so i'm excited
that i joyful
as my recovery
is
[Music]
normalization
it
right yeah
[Music]
i think it's very unfair
that there's so much corruption
and we have french and ethical business
leaders
so people and business foods
don't be ashamed to be academically
empowered
to problem-solve
you have to be prepared
to build the future that you want
however
i cannot believe the level of ignorance
like in south africa i'm not sure where
you are right now
there's equal numbers of people who will
not take them
we cannot
be productive
through my experience
that we can show that billions
[Music]
how can i become a useful member of
society
how do i use my gifts that god has given
[Music]
and that's one of the reasons i gave on
your platform
[Music]
however
i am a network i put myself in a
position
because
i just cannot
i cannot beat this empire when i'm sorry
so i have friends in australia that
invites me to come here every friday and
the amount
wow i have friends in the united states
i have a friend in poland he's 25 years
old he's gonna do his phd i've written
just happening in japan with trying to
innovate in medical technology
so i am trapped
i have a daughter
just completed a master's
but
[Music]
an anxiety
right
i mean it's i i think that you know what
you're articulating here you know
obviously every every every person has
their fear and you know covet is
treating every person in unprecedented
ways what i'm what i'm gathering this
inspiration here is is your resilience
and your
your strategy way of thinking counseling
to the future and constantly thinking
okay well this happened now now what's
what's what's the future now and how do
i adapt now and and how do i move
forward and take one more step and one
more step and think critically into the
future and i and and i i'm really
inspired by that and i think that you
know i'm really honored to have been
able to to give some platform to hear
your story and i'm sure that this story
will be told many more times with you
and but but i'm but i'm very very
honored for you have chosen to come to
come to this show now vanessa what i
would also love to is to get to know you
a little bit better from your from your
background and i have a few short
questions
um
for the end of the episode and and i'd
love to take you back a little bit to
your childhood and i'd love to know you
know what really fascinated you as a kid
you know before all of this you know
when you were just a kid what would
really spark your curiosity
[Music]
amazing amazing and what what really
inspires you today you know in your
day-to-day life right now what really
inspires you
you know i gotta say good jobs and life
i was on my dead men
and the loss of demons i know what you
don't know
i know what love feels like
i know that what general what it feels
like i know what every flower dilemma
that my gate feels like and i know what
prayer some more demons
[Music]
humanity because
i can also be very difficult
so i wanna tell people when the jumps
are down
human beings are beautiful and we've
experienced love so inspired by love
i love it amazing and what are three
words that you would use to describe
yourself
[Music]
but i'm also
humane
amazing
amazing and so so tenacious and what are
a few other words
my
[Music]
no i i i can't imagine uh you know the
the the the change of mentality and the
resilience that you have to go with and
and i'm really inspired by your story
and i really want to thank you for
coming on the show this was really
wonderful and i can't wait to share this
with the world and and thank you for the
positive impact you're making and for
inspiring and myself and many others and
vanessa stay safe and stay healthy thank
you
[Music]